hi everyone benedict cumberbatch here
with my good friend benedict wong from
marvel studios doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
often benedicts and i both get asked
does it ever get confusing having the
same name as your co-star benedict the
truth is there is no one else i'd rather
share that name with that being said it
does help to have a nickname at times so
today we're going to review some of the
ones you've come up with
no pressure then
benny d
has it benny
what okay that's a different character
biddy
no okay
that's a
interesting bandeau box that's uh yeah
no that's not good eggs benedict thanks
bennett eggs eggs it's my poker name
yeah benny dewan
benny dog sorry
suffice to say benedict and i are going
to stick with our given names actually i
i like the sound of benny d what yeah
well it feels fresh cool without trying
too hard i'm sure it does not sound cool
it doesn't sound like you're jealous
though i picked it first
not at all
[Music]
you